you make a black woman so upset with you  for whatever [ __ ] you're doing and  she pulls her earring off and goes what  just go nothing nothing and you run  and you find shelter  and may I suggest a body of water  some of you are going to be pretty  surprised by this next part because a  lot of you think I think black people  don't swim and that's the craziest thing  I've ever heard in my whole life you  can't think an entire group of people  doesn't do one thing I know black people  swim I've seen black people swim what I  have never seen and no one has is a  black woman that just got her hair done  get it wet on purpose thank you  a black woman Will Follow You into a  body of water but just up to her hair  and then she'd be like uh nope and back  it on out I saw a black lady leave a  hair salon one time started raining on  her hair and she looked up into the sky  and she goes no and it stopped raining  still think Jesus is white